to india now where confirmed infections
and deaths in a devastating second wave
have dipped below record levels
but there's concern that many cases are
not being reported
particularly from a surge in vast rural
areas
these regions lack adequate testing and
health care infrastructure
dw's nimisha jaiswal visited a village
near the city of mirot in uttar pradesh
where there has been a spike in deaths
caused by fever
it has been an exhausting month for saya
chauhan
for weeks his son haseen was racked by
fever and troubled breathing
chauhan who raises cattle for a living
finally arranged a car to take his son
to the hospital in the city
has seen tested positive for the
coronavirus
four days later he was discharged not
because he was feeling better
but because they had already racked up a
bill of about 1500 euros
haseem a daily wager earns 5 euros a day
when he can find work he didn't improve
at all at the hospital
we somehow arranged an oxygen cylinder
at home with great difficulty
i had to borrow money from several
people we didn't have a rupee
but for your child you'll do anything
the family of 30 lives crammed together
in close quarters they have been lucky
that no one else was taken seriously ill
and even luckier to get a diagnosis
many are falling sick in this village
which lies a hundred kilometers east of
the national capital
but there is no testing here there are
no government health facilities in this
village
small private clinics like this one are
the only stop gap
and have fielded hundreds of complaints
or fever in the last month alone
they do not have the provisions to treat
the coronavirus
and refer patients to the city but
treatment there is expensive
and given the curfew it is very
difficult to even travel there
so neil kumar has a car and could afford
treatment for his father and siblings
he even arranged beds through a contact
he lost all three of them last week the
doctors
asked the family to arrange medicines
but they were sold counterfeit bottles
the overwhelmed hospital charged twice
as much for services
recounting the horrors of what he saw
kumar is skeptical about the number of
deaths being reported
in the state i kept getting calls from
the authorities for three days after my
father's death
asking after his health i told them he'd
passed away
i don't even know if his death was
counted in the statistics
i saw eight bodies carried out of the
hospital the day my father died
from my family without diagnosis
fever deaths are on the rise jameel
johan a social worker
describes what has been happening first
they have a fever
then they feel breathless many
eventually die
at home in this house someone died
in that house too johan says there are
50 fresh graves in this cemetery alone
residents say cases of fevers started
spiking after rallies were held here for
local elections last month
johan started making a list of deaths in
the village
the cause of death for most is fever and
breathlessness
almost none of these have been recorded
as coronavirus deaths
every day people are dying nobody has
been tested
we haven't been told anything about the
vaccine no one here has gotten it
no doctors have visited us for the last
year
this village has been relatively
untouched by the pandemic
now residents are terrified they fear
that as recorded cases flag in urban
india
the corona virus will continue to wreck
unseen havoc here
for more i'm now joined by our
correspondent misha jaiswal who filed
that report
namisha we're seeing official numbers at
least heading in the right direction
which is a good sign but it seems that
india's
covert 19 crisis has shifted from urban
centers
to the countryside what does that mean
for the country's fight against covert
rebecca it mainly means that the
optimism we can feel about
numbers dipping may be too early
especially as we're hearing more and
more reports much
like in the village that we visited that
there have been many fevers
and many deaths which have been
completely missed
by the coronaval statistics that we are
feeling good about right now
of course india's numbers continue to be
above 200
000 above 200 000 a day
which is also a significant number of
course and is the highest
globally many of the infections have now
shifted from major centers like delhi
and mumbai to other smaller cities
but even then these are the numbers that
do still get recorded
even in the cities many struggled to get
tested at the peak
of the search and now there are large
swaths of the country that are being
completely missed when it comes to
testing
and this definitely impacts india's
ability to respond to the virus
if it's completely been missed in so
many places
what is the government doing to respond
to this crisis
well the good news is that the crisis in
rural india
has been acknowledged prime minister
modi said that local leaders
as well as local health care workers
will play a large role
in fighting the crisis in rural india so
this has been taken note of by the
national government
however there are large holes in
healthcare infrastructure
as well as logistics which is not
something that you should be reacting to
as the crisis is developing much as what
we saw in the oxygen crisis in the
cities
it was a bit too late to be responding
at this point of time
so right now again there are these holes
within the rural healthcare
infrastructure
that need to be urgently addressed an
additional concern is that
governments like the uttar pradesh
government and the state that we visited
have actually cracked down on villagers
for seemingly telling lies to the media
instead of rushing to their aid which
also raises further concern
that these problems are not being
acknowledged the way they should be
what more then could be or should be
done
the focus rebecca seems to be on ramping
up india's vaccination drive
just today prime minister modi said that
we must take collective responsibility
to expand the vaccination drive however
there are significant challenges the
government says that there will be a
much
larger amount of doses available by july
but right now
when anecdotally when we look at
available doses it is still a fight to
book a slot
to get an appointment especially between
the 18 and 44
age limit right now in addition even
when these doses eventually become
available
there is a high amount of hesitancy
there are many rumors and disinformation
going around
that the vaccine may actually harm you
rather than help you all of this will
need to be urgently addressed
if that third wave has to be fought off
dw correspondent namisha jaiswal in
delhi thanks very much